pull the trigger his friends to nail and
whack it in a one hit what you're
telling me is good by conventional
hammer about conventional life ran out
of gas you'll only ever get a little bit
of gas at a time
hey you noticed I'm I like to come by
and see it I like seeing you as well I
was hoping to save up to taking dinner
someplace nice I love that yeah whatever
you want by the way this one's on me
I've been thinking about this ever since
I first got gas at your place you must
be so excited
do you mean to tell me with no money
down I can buy a do you know what this
Tillerman
TV show we keep seeing this guy's
everywhere we need to know who this man
is and we need him on this show I'm
sorry about all these cheap dates this
TV stuff I'm just a little out of it but
you know the clapper yeah but I'm gonna
bounce back
what is that your head is about to
explode that's my kid you can take that
off
all right computer somebody's making
money off and it ain't us I subtract you
like five bucks right now just for
watching that recognize this man right
here yeah
do you know the clapper dirty so people
came by tonight asking all kinds of
questions they'd a photograph of you
you're in trouble no I'm not in trouble
I like you Eddie I really do wonder but
I need my job like I need my job how'd
you get this number night every night we
want you to be honest I'm not
comfortable do you not television
anywhere it stop harassing my girl
where's Judy
[Applause]
things got out of control and I didn't
know how to handle it
[Music]
the clapper it's great to finally meet
you
I mean you wanna make a big joke out of
me go ahead I just lost the only person
there matter through this whole thing I
can't tell you how nice lists good
things could come out of this
[Music]
we didn't do it again don't look at me
look at the camera you looking at me
don't look at me I know I'm talking you
but don't look at me don't look at me
look at the camera you look at me again
[Music]
you
you